the libs are going way way too far
the california state assembly has just
passed a bill
that seeks to establish california as a
sanctuary
for children seeking transgender medical
treatment as well as their pervert
parents who want to put the kids through
these kinds of genital mutilations and
experimental hormone
therapies the legislation is called
sb107
the bill's author is senator scott
weiner
because all nature is but art unknown to
thee
because that's just that's just
providence kind of winking i think just
the kind
of humorous order even to this very
fallen world uh winking through scott
weiner if you've heard that name before
we've mentioned him on the show scott
weiner is that sexual degenerate who
made it his mission his crusade in the
california legislature to soften the
punishments for pederasts for grown men
who have sex with little boys he said it
was very unfair there were there were
unfair and unequal treatments for pet
arrests and so scott weiner decided to
take up their cause and now in the least
surprising turn of events in the news
that you've ever seen the man the
degenerate who wanted to soften the
punishments for pederasty now wants a
bunch of sexually confused kids to come
to his state isn't that shocking never
never saw that one coming did you
sick stuff
only you know furthering the nickname
for los angeles and san francisco is
gamora sodom and gomorrah by the sea
uh really awful awful stuff everyone
involved in this this the senator scott
weiner the the parents the the doctors
these shaman witch doctor quacks who
were lopping off the genitals of kids or
pumping them full of hormones and and
puberty blockers to to get them ready to
start laughing off their genitals all
these people should be in prison all of
these people should be ostracized from
society there's no question about that
and i don't i don't want to hear any
states rights argument for it either
okay there's the kind of squish position
which is well listen
if california wants to lop off the
genitals of kids that's their business
that's their right that's no they don't
have a right to do that they don't scott
weiner doesn't have a right to do this
these quack doctors don't have a right
to do this the parents don't have a
right to do this either
and we're not only justified we actually
have an obligation to say that no so you
don't get to
you don't get to
put little kids through all sorts of
mutilations to make the little boy look
more like a little girl no one has the
right to do that there's no right from
democracy there's no right from the
sexual revolution or anything else when
they're not chopping up the little kids
they are they are killing the little
kids and a lot of other people too this
uh not just in california but up in
america's top hat canada
in canada now they are very heavily
pushing assisted suicide
they they use
a another euphemism it's not just
euthanasia
which was the one the euphemism for many
years for assisted suicide means a good
death even though it's not a good death
at all because suicide is the basically
the worst kind of death you can imagine
but now they call it made maid medical
assistance
in dying
and canada in over the last six or so
years has been really aggressive in
pushing assisted suicide
to the point that we're not just talking
about a few marginal cases because i
know even there are a number of
conservatives sometimes who will say
well look if an old person has all sorts
of terrible diseases and is going
through an intense amount of pain
maybe in that rare case it should be
okay for that person to be able to kill
himself
i don't think that's true but i can see
why some people might start to believe
that
but the thing about assisted suicide is
it it cannot remain just a kind of
fringe one in a million kind of case
the moment that you legalize assisted
suicide
assisted suicide is going to explode and
it's going to become a huge percentage
of the of deaths every single year this
is this is what you're seeing in canada
only recently did canada really start to
legalize assisted suicide and start to
peddle this stuff now as of last year
over three percent of deaths in canada
or are through suicide or i'm sorry
through assisted suicide there are other
suicides as well
over three percent that's a huge number
and it's only going to grow and now the
canadians are going to push it on little
kids i'm not joking
there's a piece here
is in the ottawa citizen
on expanding medical assistance in dying
to mature minors
so what they're saying is no we're not
just going to kill any little kids we're
going to kill miners who are can make
their own decisions now the thing about
minors is they can't make their own
decisions that's why we have age of
consent laws that's why it is illegal
for you right now listening to this show
to sleep with a 16 year old you can't if
you're over whatever 19 or 20 or i don't
know whatever the laws are in your state
if you're over
if you're if you're not a kid anymore
it is illegal for you to sleep with
someone who is a minor why is that
because we have age of consent laws
because we say that young people just
are not fully in command of their
faculties to make these kinds of
important decisions now the libs are
trying to turn that on their head
they're saying yes it's true a 16 year
old can't make a decision about whether
or not to have a one-night stand but a
six-year-old can make the decision about
whether to permanently destroy his or
her genitals and sterilize themselves
and give themselves all kinds of
problems and osteoporosis and all kinds
of persistent conditions for the rest of
their lives
because they do have autonomy they do
have agency
obviously they don't now canada is going
to take it even further they're going to
say hold my beer
hold hold my my labats hold my golden
molson sorry i'm just doing my jordan
peterson impression not only not only
are we going to let the children have a
one-night stand
is it becoming irish i don't know not
only are we going to let the kids chop
off their genitals
but we're going to let the kids kill
themselves as well sorry that's what
they're saying now that's insane
to clarify jordan peterson is not saying
that but all the lunatics up in canada
are saying that
they are saying that
and this is the logical conclusion of
course
it was always the logical conclusion of
all of this
which kids do you think are going to are
going to be killed through assisted
suicide do you think it's going to be
just the happy normal well no it's going
to be the disabled kids what this is
going to amount to
is
just another aspect of the system of
eugenics that the libs have been pushing
through
abortion primarily but now if they don't
get them at the very beginning of their
lives they're going to get them shortly
thereafter and they're going to say oh
you're you're disabled you're sad you're
depressed
okay 12 year old well you can make the
mature and informed decision to kill
yourself and we're going to support you
in that
ghastly ghastly stuff
there was a news story that came out
yesterday that the largest child
sacrifice in human history has just been
excavated in peru
it was not the incas but it was the
civilization before the i fear what
they're called the
chimayas or something it was the
civilization that the incas conquered
and they found 450 child sacrifices
around the age of 10 or 12 in this
altar pit
i thought wow that's pretty bad but
those guys don't have anything on modern
westerners not even close
we sacrifice 850 000 babies a year
through abortion it's not even even the
aztecs on their worst day didn't didn't
get that far
and now look at what we're doing in
canada even if you want to say
implausibly i think that babies aren't
really babies and a baby if a baby's in
the womb the baby's not really a human
being or not really alive that's a silly
argument but okay now we're talking
about kids who are like eight we're
talking about kids who are 12
and canada is saying and they're in a
really really serious sophisticated way
that justin trudeau you know smiley
really nice happy way yes we're gonna
let the disabled kids die we're gonna
kill them we're gonna have doctors kill
the disabled kids if they get a little
sad sometimes and that'll be better for
everybody don't you think no of course
not
of course not we all know that this is
evil
okay the left
is for it because the left supports evil
things that's just what the left is that
even the very term left in politics
comes out of the french revolution and
it was the people who sat on the left of
the national assembly who were attacking
the church it's just an attack on god
when it really gets down to it that's
what leftism is
so the we all know it's evil the left is
for it because the left supports evil
things and the right is just kind of
impotent because the the right can't
really articulate the definition between
good and evil some conservatives can but
the ones who have fallen into the
squishiness of the you do you and well
who's to say what's good or bad man or
don't force me to do anything or i'm not
going to impose my views on anybody man
whatever you know they adopt all of
these kind of silly
libertarian-ish platitudes
they can't articulate what to do about
this
the only language that the right has
been able to use in recent decades is
the language of autonomy the language of
choice
so they're going to say well if they
oppose this at all they're going to say
well it's wrong because
the kids can't choose the kids can't
freely consent
it's fine for adults to kill themselves
but it's wrong for kids because the kids
can't freely consent that's not
primarily what's wrong with it the thing
that's primarily wrong with it is that
it is always wrong to kill yourself it's
a grave grave sin because you do not own
your body you didn't bring yourself into
this world you have no right to bring
yourself out of this world your life is
a gift to you from god you are a steward
of yourself and your body and you have
responsibilities you don't just get to
do whatever the hell you want to do all
the time
you have duties and responsibilities to
the moral order which is real
and which we in our country are are
denying every bit as much we want to
talk we talk about evil empires you know
the soviet union and what genuinely was
an evil empire and we talk about evil
empires like the aztecs and all those
people practicing human sacrifice down
there in latin america well i think the
moderns ought to take a little look in
the mirror okay
before you accuse me take a look at
yourself because the stuff that we're
delving into right now
really really wicked stuff would make
the aztecs
blush
i'm glad you like that clip now hold on
you got to ring that bell ring that bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]